okay today i'm going to talk to you
about alkali metal reactions
so alkali metals are in group one of the
periodic table
they are lithium sodium potassium
rubidium caesium and francium
there's a pattern as you go down the
table in terms of reactivity
at the very top so lithium
is the least reactive and the further
you go
down group one the more and more
reactive you get
until you get to the bottom we have
francium which is the most reactive
now what we need to know about is how
alkaline metals react
with water we're going to
pay particular attention to these first
three
lithium sodium and potassium so
imagine if i have a tub of water
like this so here is my tub of water
now these alkali metals are very
reactive metals they're so reactive
that they react with water so if i had
my metal
and i put it into the water i would see
a reaction
now the reaction is slightly different
depending on which alkali metal
we have so first of all um all of them
so all of these three that we're
learning about would
start fizzing and skimming across the
surface
i would also see um a gas being produced
as well so
fizzing and a gas being produced
so for lithium i would see fizzing
and it moving across the surface now
sodium is more reactive so
it's so um reactive that it would in
fact it would start to melt
as it moved round the surface i might
even see
a yellow flame apologies you can't see
that particularly well but a yellow
flame
now potassium is even more reactive
so it has an even more vigorous reaction
even more fizzing
and quite often um we will see
a lilac flame
so we could actually see a much more
vigorous reaction
now the reason why we get a flame is
because the gas produced
is hydrogen
and hydrogen is a flammable gas we know
that
because of the squeaky pop test is the
test for hydrogen
because we literally set fire to the
hydrogen and it
um yeah it's flammable so
what we need to do now is we need to
have a quick look
at the equations associated with
reacting an alkali metal with water
so i think it's best to look at a
particular example we're going to have a
look at lithium
then potassium so imagine if i add
lithium
to water this is how i write that
these have reacted together now i always
produce
two particular products a hydroxide
in this case lithium hydroxide
hydroxide and hydrogen
gas now
these are the two things that i'll
always produce a hydroxide
and hydrogen the identity of the
hydroxide depends upon
the alkali metal that i've used and
we'll see that in a minute
now these hydroxides
they are alkaline
and i could test for that for example by
adding universal indicator to this water
once it's reacted because i should see
it turning
maybe a bluey purpley color to indicate
that it's now
alkaline so let's have a look
at the symbol equation that goes with
that so lithium
is just the metal by itself water we
should know is h2o
lithium hydroxide is nice and simple
lioh
and hydrogen is h2 and to balance it
we just need two in front of those ones
like that
so what i want to do is i want to
compare what this reaction would look
like
if we were using potassium rather than
lithium
so i'm going to write it here so this
time i've got potassium
plus water so
this time i still produce a hydroxide
but the name of this hydroxide instead
of being lithium hydroxide is going to
be
potassium hydroxide
so again i'm forming hydroxide and
just like before i'm still producing
hydrogen gas
now the symbol equation is going to be
very similar simple very similar as well
so i've got k for potassium
water we know is h2o potassium hydroxide
so it's not going to be
lioh it's just going to be koh
and then plus hydrogen which is h2 again
and the balancing is going to be
absolutely identical
so the important thing to remember is
the reactivity
increases the further you go down the um
the alkali metals group one metals um
the gas produces hydrogen which is
flammable and we also produce a
hydroxide
the name of that hydroxide depends upon
your reactant which alkali metal you've
used
thank you